Rick Pearlstein what is in your book
before the storm about very Goldwater
well the second half of the book is a
blow-by-blow account of the 1964
presidential election all the drama
therein and what happens in the first
half is I tell kind of two intertwined
stories the one is the rise of the
conservative movement from something
that was a really marginal in American
politics in the 50s - a movement that
had basically taken over its own
political party the Republicans by 1964
the other kind of braid and the argument
is how America changed in the process
how America changed from a country of
what I would call consensus or what at
least primary people believed was
consensus which most people agreed with
each other and the broad goals of
society and broadest kind of political
questions - one that were more familiar
with when we think about the 60s in
which the nation is one that's divided
against itself who won in 1964 who ran
against this was the Goldwater Johnson
election Goldwater against Lyndon
Johnson and Barry Goldwater lost in the
biggest popular landslide up to that
point even worse than Elfland in 1936
Emily Emily states did Barry Goldwater
win there we go I don't win six states
he won quite comfortably in five states
in the deep south which I'm sure we'll
want to talk about
he won Arizona his home state only by a
whisker and of course the guy who beat
him was Lyndon Johnson and after the
election passed and it's the Wednesday
after election before saying
conservatism was finished for good that
we've now lived in a liberal Republic
that if the Republican Party ever veered
from the center and embraced
conservatism and it's as its organizing
principle there wouldn't be a Republican
Party and there might not even exist a
two-party system that's how kind of
discombobulating this whole thing was in
American history when did you first
think about doing a book like this you
know I came to New York from graduate
school in 1994 where graduate school at
the University of Michigan I went to
college at the University Chicago from
native of Milwaukee
and I decided to strike out to the big
city academia seemed a little too
confining for I think what were my
political social intellectual ambitions
and I got a job at a magazine called
lingua franca do you know that magazine
what's it stand for what is lingua
franca : the review of academic life
it's been described a little
uncharitably as the academics People
magazine but it's it's it's more like a
general interest magazine for academics
it has articles about new intellectual
trends university controversies it's a
fun magazine written in a general
interest tone that deals with what
happens in universities and that was a
really important experience for me but
that was right around the time of the
1994 midterm congressional elections I
come from a campus based environment in
which a lot of the thinking was quite
conventionally left-wing at least in the
humanities department I was in and I had
come right from college I hadn't seen
too much of the world and that 1994
election really startled me it just
startled me to realize how much
grassroots anger there was at ideas that
I took almost for granted not for
granted because you know my family is
relatively conservative and you know I
certainly knew Republicans and
conservatives but it still came as a
surprise to me and the anger and the
passion and then not too many months
later was the Oklahoma City bombing and
the idea that that people could get so
passionate about these right-wing ideas
you know no reason to equate what
Timothy McVeigh did with what Newt
Gingrich was up to but I just remember
before that bombing listening to
right-wing talk radio which I started
doing and just being astonished at how
much anger there was and really kind of
coming around to the idea that people
can really be politically incommensurate
I mean absolutely be coming from exact
opposite directions
when confronted over the same
set of facts so you're in New York City
working at lingua franca yeah that's a
and why barry goldwater again where did
you get to him and have you ever met him
or did you ever see him in your life
well I I paid this application at the
foot of his driveway Paradise Valley in
Phoenix he passed away while I was
researching this book in fact I was at
the Lyndon Baines Johnson library in
Austin I heard the news and I never got
a chance to meet him he was basically
not well enough to to be interviewed by
the time I got around to this project
but why Barry Goldwater start reading
books about conservatism I didn't even
know conservatism even had history I
mean it seemed to me that there had
always been these conservatives and
they'd always fought liberals and the
Liberals were the Democrats and the
conservatives were the Republicans and
immediately when I started reading a bit
of history and seeing us how marginal
this movement was in the 50s
I began pursuing just the plot basically
how did conservatives become more
powerful and every road led to Barry
Goldwater in this 1964 campaign it was
the glue that tied together hundreds of
disparate elements there's one note in
the back though that kind of connects
all this in your acknowledgments kind of
one of them up my dog's right ya know
not to die all the dogs were interesting
Buster and checkers it's the note about
the review was written for Sue and John
Leonard at the nation yeah John Leonard
that we see on CBS in the morning yeah
sue his wife his wife she's a history
teacher at a prep school and in New York
and they were the literary editors the
nation so I mean maybe you're getting at
the fact that I'm a left winger I'm a
confirmed
I don't even call myself a liberal I'd
even consider myself a little bit to the
left of liberal and you know that I
spent you know it's time writing the 700
page book four years of my life immersed
in the Arcana of the conservative
movement really not what I was getting
at as much as the John Leonard used to
be the National Review yes that's right
do you remember I write in the book
about
National Review in the mid-50s basically
being the most exciting thing on the
literary scene in a lot of ways because
it really was this kind of Eisenhower
conformist time and Bill Buckley was a
Hellion I mean I say that Yale hadn't
seen a crew as reckless and and kind of
off-the-wall as his until 1968 you know
he would do things like he would go to a
George a Henry Wallace rally for those
friends and Platt to release a flock of
pigeons you know into the amphitheater
as Wallace spoke about appeasement with
Russia you know this kind of anarchic
counter establishment spirit was a
something that resided in National
Review and attracted a lot of talented
young writers who wouldn't necessarily
go on to become conservatives one of
them was John Leonard another was Joan
Didion Arlen Croce the dance critic at
The New Yorker and most interestingly he
even wrote a memoir about it Garry wills
so why a review in the nation why did
that have what did that have to do with
again getting this book on that was that
the the review was of a big novelty and
I remember called Infinite Jest by David
Foster Wallace that's like 1500 page
novel and I guess I you know I just it
caught the eye of some people and one of
the people that caught the eye of was
the guy who ended up becoming my editor
at Farrar Straus and Giroux a friend of
mine Paul Elie and he just called me up
and said you know want to have lunch are
you working on a book and that was
really one of the things that got me
started for all practical purposes on
well that little thing you got your
hands there now there's a nut let me ask
you that did the concerns you talked
about how many people did you interview
about 50 I'm kind of counting my in-laws
so you know maybe 40 or 50 why Jennifer
your in-laws my in-laws were members of
young Americans for freedom they were
from Jersey City and one of the kind of
off the beaten track stories I tell in
the book is how
a lot of kids growing up in towns
controlled by corrupt democratic
machines kind of became Republican out
of that same kind of an anarchic kind of
anti-establishment spirit they saw the
RUP of the Republicans as the rebellious
party in a place like Jersey City or
maybe Chicago or you know Tammany Hall
in New York and they were so disgusted
by the kidney machine in Jersey City and
of course they had conservative
instincts that they embrace this
movement what are your in-laws name so
the gyres Hank and Kathy pink and Patty
guy my wife's name is Kathy we're
actually getting married in two weeks
what did they tell you what did you
learn from them well I learned a couple
of things first of all that there were
the only two people and their precinct
to vote for Barry Goldwater in their
whole precinct in Jersey City and second
of all my father-in-law Hank was
basically an accountant in Korea in the
early 60s when the Vietnam War was still
very much a kind of fugitive underground
subject that wasn't being kind of
discussed in public and he was wondering
why he was asked to sign off and I'll
use requisitions for helicopters that
they never saw they were of course being
diverted to help our advisors in Vietnam
did did you did you the people you talk
to the conservative you talk to you know
that your politics were over on the Left
well that was always fun i i i would
always straightforwardly describe my
project and would kind of you know i i'm
not one to you know hide my leonard or
bushel but i didn't you know run out
there and say well you know i'm i'm for
socialized medicine or anything like
that so I go and see a conservator like
Richard Vickery a guy who co-founded the
moral majority and after interviewing
him about his experience and he was the
guy who basically took the direct mail
list from the Barry mole
well Goldwater campaign and turned it
into this
activist tool they say a lot of
conservative mailing lists still are
kind of based in the spine of that one
master mailing list of people gave money
to Barry Goldwater I go into his office
in Virginia we talked for an hour or
whatever and he says well it's just you
know so great the young people are
following up on the history of our
movement doesn't say anything
another fellow I interviewed named Lee
Edwards he's a a Heritage Foundation guy
he wrote a biography of Barry Goldwater
and I think he he caught me staring
longingly at a kind of a left-wing
poster that he ironically put up at the
wall and he had me pegged and at the end
he said I wish more of our young
conservatives were as interested in the
history or our movement as you are you
did say and here's some nice things
about Lee Edwards though you say that
you recommended that people read his
book basically under notes I mean do you
find that to be a reliable book on Barry
Goldwater because some of the books you
don't you're not that happy with no
that's that's a pretty reliable book
yeah although I found myself forced to
also say some not so nice things about
Lee Edwards
to be perfectly frank because in the
historical sources I was looking at he
was very young and inexperienced at the
time and he worked for Barry GU when he
worked for Barry Goldwater as a
publicist in 1964 and he made some
youthful mistakes perfectly
understandable but that was more of an
indictment of the general kind of shabby
Nisour the campaign its disorganization
its vacuum of leadership the top which
is probably you know a funny part of my
book more than more than you know
anything aim to you know taking out
anyone living or dead it was this
sentence that I want to ask you about
the breakfast David Cain set up for me
with a cadre of conservative movement
veterans at the Capitol Hill Club was
very helpful and very cool yeah those
last time I wore the suit actually
normally we don't find you in a suit and
tie yeah in my overalls or sweat pants
you know over the computer but
conservatives were extremely forthcoming
and generous with their recollections
people turned over their files to me one
guy you know let me room through a
storage room for you know a couple days
david keene set up this breakfast I have
no idea if he had any clue about my
political leanings he never asked and he
arranged a breakfast at the Capitol Hill
Club which is habituated by Republican
politicians in Capitol Hill staffers and
so I got the sat there any breakfast
with him who he's the head of the
American Conservative Union longtime
conservative activist since 1964 and
Alfred Regnery who's conservative
publisher Allen risk and who is a
longtime editor of Human Events the
conservative magazine and that a couple
of people kind of drifted over they
didn't know to offer their own Rock
recollections about Barry Goldwater
then you say those who went beyond the
call of duty include Jameson campaign
jr. who gets triple recognition for
opening his storehouse of paper that's a
guy yeah
and for publishing so many of the
biographies and memoirs of conservative
figures that I relied upon Ottawa
Illinois you know I've never met Jameson
campaign but I know Ottawa all know it's
the first lincoln-douglas debate site
yeah it's it's have you been there yeah
I I'm like I say I'm originally from
Milwaukee took my parents car and drove
down there one day he is a pretty
remarkable guy he is a true blue
movement conservative who believes in
the maximalist conception of
conservatism uncompromising and like a
lot of conservative activists he's an
ideological and cultural entrepreneurs
started his own publishing company and
it's you know there in Ottawa Illinois
he publishes all these memoirs and
biographies the conservative figures
people like I have to F clipped in white
it was a big moving force in the
Goldwater organization a Glen Campbell
is his newest book his memoirs are
coming out very soon he was the head of
Hoover Institute all kinds of Richard
Kleindienst who probably knew the Nixon
Attorney General who was also a great
friend of Barry Goldwater's and
no key in the same storehouse where it
keeps a spare books he has these piles
of bouldering reams of documents and so
you know who's good enough though just
let me around there for three or four
days did he know your politics well he
came to them know them because I also we
had several extensive interviews he may
have even known beforehand did he care
well I tell a story in the book about
how young Americans for freedom members
in New York City the you know
conservative firebrands and the the
remnants of the young socialist League
used to get together at the White Horse
saloon you know the famous bar well the
Bohemians used to hang out and they
would they would go in the back room and
argue politics and then drink beers and
then sing old socialist songs and what
they said was in this kind of conformist
kind of age in which the politics is is
politics are so far from the center of
people's passions there were only people
we could find to talk to and I think
people who love politics people who love
ideological politics and politics driven
by ideas and principles and passions you
know they'd like to mix it up they think
politics is fun so I never had any
problem having a great conversation a
fruitful conversation with any
conservative so when you wrote the book
did you approach it some way to either
put your views in or not put your views
in what was your approach to it it's
kind of something that the reader has to
judge my main approach was literary my
style of writing political history is
quite literary in the sense that I I try
to craft the sentences in ways that are
rhythmic and you know introduce the
themes and character and psychological
motives but I'm the same it's the same
time I try and allow the reader a novel
is something you complete as you read
you know there's no one interpretation
of it and I try and leave some room for
ambiguity about what I think and what I
believe and try to kind of have my
political points kind of waft up gently
from the text rather than explicitly
stated so it'll be a
matter of judgment for the readers how
much of my politics come through some of
got it right
some have got it wrong no one has said
oh he's a liberal he shouldn't be doing
this people have been very accepting but
the main enemy my book after all isn't
really conservatives it's kind of boring
boring snappy pundits and people who
take it upon themselves to explain
America to America and often do do so
with you know honest blinders on as a
matter of fact you quote hunted after
pundit and most of them known in in the
history of pundit tree is being liberal
being wrong and you start off your your
book by quoting a couple of these
instead of trying to find a well-known
you Scotty Reston it's the first
paragraph for the book yeah yeah I've
got it
and the president yeah here it is he has
wrecked his party for a long time to
come and is not even likely to control
the wreckage Richard Rovere yeah The New
Yorker the election has finished the
Goldwater school of political reaction
by every test we have declared James
MacGregor burns one of the nation's
esteemed scholars of the presidency this
is as surely a liberal epic as the late
19th century was a conservative one yeah
actually the first quote was from Scotty
Reston
that's his reqtest party for a long time
to come and one more from Arthur
Schlessinger quoting according governor
Dewey saying that if the party's
realigned along ideological axes left
and right that there were Democrats win
every election and the Republicans would
lose every election every one of them
180-degree is wrong why do you think
they got it so wrong well I actually
published an article on this very
subject it was the cover article the
April 23rd issue of the nation which
some you're Logie or newsstands may
still have and you know I I make a
pretty strong argument about why they
get things wrong mainly it's for
deigning it to try and predict the
future in the first place but I think
kind of pundits have kind of a
structural bias and Fay
of pretending this level of authority
and knowledge that they couldn't
possibly have it's kind of how they gain
the illusion of authority and you know I
mean in my opinion you know this is an
argument I make I think it's a little
bit of an abuse of authority and I think
it does damage to democracy and the the
predictions that pundits tend to make
tend to have a certain structure they
tend to always prevail towards the
center rather than any ideological
extreme ideological extremes tend to get
discounted as you know just really not
worthy of the American creed and
unfortunately the only time American
history tends to change is with the boot
from an ideological extreme left or
right I mean that's just a historical
fact in the back one last note on the
acknowledgments you think the National
Endowment of the humanities what they do
for you well big government they handed
me a very generous check as part of
their independent Scholars Program I
applied for a year's fellowship that
entails of writing up a prospectus to
your project and getting recommendations
from professionals
I got recommendations from historian
Michael Hazen historian named Nelson
Lichtenstein and historian named Thomas
a group all of them scholars of post-war
American history and they saw worth my
project and gave me enough money to
cover my income freighter you think your
own politics have anything to do with
why they gave you the money I don't
think there was any indication of what
my politics were and I mean well I
shouldn't say that because you know
grantsmanship is a pretty political game
and all these historians that happen to
recommend me are associated with the
left yeah really I don't I don't I don't
care to speculate I just you know was
glad to get it and I think that
it's a democratically accountable
process you know in this kind of
conservative age we forget that the
civil servants are basically people we
indirectly hire and fire and you know
that was part of the part of the
decision people made in November of 2000
if they thought you know the democratic
regime was giving grants to wild-eyed
liberals that maybe that was why they
voted for Bush let me go back when I was
18 years old and worked at a radio
station in Indiana I used to have to
push a button I don't remember what
night it was maybe Sunday night and the
next thing you heard after I pushed the
tape to run mm-hmm the Mannion forum
you're you carried it the station
carried it those things I worked at
carried it and it was Dean Mannion and I
don't I must say I didn't know much
about Dean Mannion at those days I knew
that the only I knew is he was from
South Bend Indiana you know far too much
now Dean
Clarence Pat Mannion who was he and why
does he matter in this book well he is
serious he's a figure that's been
obscured by history he was a law
professor at notre Dom a former New Deal
liberal who really made a quite dramatic
conversion to conservatism in the 40s
kind of the Brit his bridge to
conservatism ironically enough was that
he was anti interventionist he didn't
believe America should get involved in
world war two and that was kind of a
that was both a left wing and a right
wing kind of movement you know some of
his friends in that movement were people
like robert maynard hutchins the head of
the university of chicago and a
prominent liberal you know aj musty who
would later go on to become a prominent
you know anti Vietnam activist but he
really was influenced by people like
Colonel McCormack a publisher of the
Chicago Tribune into basically hating
the New Deal and all its works and he
just became more and more convinced of
this calling to spread the gospel that
the New Deal was this cancer on American
society in that internal subversion from
communism and the McCarthy mold was
rotting America from within that he
became more and more activist he retired
as dean from the Notre Dame Law School
he started this radio program that you
refer to the Mannion from the Mannion
forum of the air and he just preached
the conservative true religion to
whatever stations would take him he
would have guests like Barry Goldwater
and segregationist from the south and he
just kind of became more and more driven
by the idea of winning conservative
political power now he had to I remember
he had to pay to get on the station
did he yeah that's new to me I'm not
surprised though he had lots of appealed
lots of backers among this certain kind
of corporation a small family-owned
manufacturing corporation that tend to
be the social base for the conservatives
in the 40s and 50s and they you know he
he was a master fund raiser did you
listen to any of the Mannion program oh
sure I have some of my home yeah what
did you hear from him what would you
what he sound like why did he say what
did he sound like him in the grain of
his voice I mean just basically when you
listened to him what did you was he was
he a Carl McIntyre type did you mention
in the book the author Hellfire and
brimstone guy he he sounded very quiet
reasonable he he wasn't intellectual you
know he framed himself as an
intellectual and I think that was his
particular power I mean the Hellfire and
brimstone guys had their own power but
his power was convincing people who were
out there that this wasn't just the
province of nuts and already in 1956
he's back from a presidential candidate
this guy who used to be the IRS
commissioner for Eisenhower but came out
against the income tax and ran a
third-party presidential campaign that
Manion was instrumental in in his name
Coleman Coleman Andrews yeah whatever
happened to Coleman Enders brother what
happened to call me anxious I don't know
do you know maybe they run did he win
did he get a vote he ran in 1956 you
know those you know basically every four
years there was always some kind of
third segregationist challenger to the
two parties sometimes they get 1%
sometimes they get 2% sometimes they get
3% kind of like the Nader movement today
I think that Coleman Andrews got less
than 2
you got maybe seven or eight percent in
Virginia but the idea wasn't necessarily
to give him 50 51 percent of the vote
Manny was a strategist he knew that if
he could deny in 1956 in the case in
1956 Eisenhower on the one hand and
Stevenson on the other the majority of
electoral college votes then the
election would be thrown to the House of
Representatives and if if if this guy
Coleman Andrews who believed in
abolishing the income tax and was a
segregationist won a single electoral
vote they could use that vote to barter
for concessions from the Democrats from
the Republicans whoever but you really I
mean you lead off your book with
Clarence Mannion yeah you imply that
he's the guy that started the whole
Goldwater's well and this is how he
started it he was he was he set the bomb
in that they're casting about for
someone to run in 1960 he comes to like
Barry Goldwater and he comes up with
this idea why don't we have Barry
Goldwater while we ghost write a book
for Barry Goldwater put his name in the
cover they talked to Goldwater he says
well whatever do it if I like it I'll
sign off on it and you know doesn't
think much of it because people were
always coming to him with these crackpot
schemes this was just one more crazy
idea and they literally put this guy
book together and a shoestring guys
who'd never been involved in publishing
made all kinds of mistakes there were
you know comic mistakes you know you
know um Keystone Cops mistakes and but
the book came out they actually called
it a pamphlet called conscience of a
conservative three years it had it and
it sold 3.5 million books Shepherdsville
Kentucky where the printing plant
happened to be suddenly became the
center of the publishing world he says
127 pages very slight yeah sold for how
much in those days you know I think that
the hardcover sold for $3 a dollar went
to the Goldwater Draft Goldwater for
president campaign in 1960 a dollar went
to whatever guy happened to sell it
where there was a bookseller or
a conservative activists who might sell
like by like 10,000 copies and give him
out to his friends and put the dollar in
the you know the kitty anyway and a
dollar went to you know this publishing
company who wrote that book
well that was written by elfbrandt
bozell now we have a brent bozell in
american politics today that's right
that's Brent Bozell the third the guy
who wrote conscience of a conservative
was a national review editor
Brent fava sell jr. Brent Bozell the
second William F Buckley best friend you
married William F Buckley sister and you
know for there's those who care to
follow these these matters his ideology
was a little different from that of
demanding conservatives the Manion
conservatives still had this one foot in
isolationism which was really being
rolled over by the juggernaut of history
let me read what you wrote about first
man you say and you write he done
friends friends of friends and friends
of friends of friends and mostly family
owned manufacturers then there's a quote
the left-wing please remember rant is
pitch is strong well organized and well
financed many gigantic fortunes built by
the virtue of private enterprises to the
Constitution have fallen under the
direction of internationalists one
worlders socialist communist much of
this vast hoard of money is being used
to socialize the United States unquote
yeah and if we have one person in mind
for that indictment it would have to be
Nelson Rockefeller a guy who's you know
who's whose grandfather created the
greatest oil fortune in history billions
of dollars and his ancestors promptly
come along and support all kinds of
welfare state measures you know all
kinds of foreign aid the kind of things
that were really anathema to Manion and
his circle so you have Clarence Manning
with his radio program
how many radio stations did you ever
find out yeah there were several hundred
growing all the time you know growing
all through 1964 and beyond he was on a
couple television stations as well and
you had the conscience of a conservative
still three and a half million copies
written by Brenton total stunner
you know it's Barry Goldwater's name on
yeah I mean people thought it would sell
10,000 copies William F Buckley said
well Robert taff's book didn't selling
he thinks - why should Barry Goldwater's
book sell and you had the National
Review that's right which had a circular
maybe a hundred thousand but you know a
very active passionate subscriber base
what was the relationship between Bill
Buckley and Barry Goldwater I would have
to say that it's complicated one bill
buckley really counted himself as kind
of a political pragmatist and his great
goal in founding National Review was to
create a conservative platform and which
a presidential candidate could run he
just don't think Barry Goldwater was the
guy he had distrust in Goldwater's
abilities in fact he was buttonholed
that by a by a Time magazine reporter to
party you said you don't really believe
that Barry Goldwater could actually be a
successful president and bukka said well
of course not and he almost threw a
little cold water on the whole Barry
Goldwater campaign in 1964 as it was
gearing up he saw it as as a lot of
people involved it is not an attempt to
win the presidency so much as to build a
movement that could lose but going to
fight a hundred battles more more of our
interview with Rick Pearlstein in just a
moment mr. pearl Stein's look at Barry
Goldwater's political life is only one
of nearly 80 stories taken from the past
15 years of booknotes TV interviews
found now in book notes on American
character people politics and conflict
in American history it's available in
bookstores and online and now back to
our booknotes interview with rick
Pearlstein cover of your book has this
picture on it Barry Goldwater where'd
you get that well I mentioned all the
the conservatives who so generously got
in touch with me I took out one of those
little ads in the New York Times Book
Review said I'm writing a book about
Barry Goldwater recollections documents
whatever our welcome sent to this
address one of the things I got in the
mail was a black-and-white picture that
had been cut off from an issue of People
magazine from a guy named Andrew Xanten
who is right now collaborating with
Senator Edie Brooke
it's not the late center but the former
Massachusetts and around his memoirs he
sent it to me said I saw this this is a
great picture I filed it away didn't
think anything more of it when it came
time to talk to the designers at the
publishing company or what the book was
gonna look like I dug up this picture I
said well maybe you can use this
somewhere it turned out to be this
glorious transcendent it's just
incredibly a well composed color picture
and one that serves one of the arguments
in my book quite well you see Barry
Goldwater you see his cowboy hat you see
a suede jacket his blue jeans the I
don't remember if it was a rifle or a
shotgun someone someone made the
correction for me and his knee Camelback
Mountain that great beautiful element in
the Phoenix landscape in the background
it looks like he's you know the Marlboro
Man but if you look carefully between
the white star in the middle and his
blue jeans you can see his pool
furniture Barry Goldwater was a pretty
self traumatizing guy he really bought
into the mythos of the West and the
individual conquering the frontier but
of course he hadn't done any conquering
himself by the time he came along his
father was millionaire you know he he
gambled around Phoenix and didn't have
to carry any money because every store
would just charge whatever he wanted to
his father you know he was he was a rich
comfortable man and in fact the
Goldwater fortune as I go to great
lengths to to recall people to was
really wouldn't have existed if it
weren't for strong federal intervention
into the economy of Arizona so one of
the goals of the New Deal was to
economically develop the south in the
southwest and one of the ways the party
of Franklin Roosevelt was later rewarded
was that the Southwest largely turned
against the New Deal and the government
programs that had been so instrumental
in turning these areas from waste lands
without electricity and water into you
know worthy parts of American
civilization Barry Goldwater had
how many different offices in the public
world over his lifetime he was he had
two he was a member of the Phoenix City
Council in the 40s and later became the
chairman he was elected by his his
colleagues as the chairman and he was
the senator from Arizona elected on two
different occasions in first and 50 to
serve until 1964 he had to leave the
Senate to run for president and he
wanted to see back in 1968
now why would Clarence Mannion be
interested in Barry Goldwater mm-hmm or
why would Bill Buckley huh at what point
did he become a national figure well he
really emerged as a national figure in
1957 in 1958 and that came through a
highly polished and dramatic showdown
with the union leader Walter Reuther a a
self-professed socialist or Social
Democrat in the Union and the European
Molde who really more than any union
leader before him saw the goal of the
union movement as sharing in state power
and working tirelessly for the promotion
of a left-wing social agenda what's this
we're looking at that's great
it says know your opponents here's the
labor slate study it carefully Walter
Reuther for president well through
Walter Reuther for Vice President Walter
Reuther for Attorney General because of
his politics and because of what seemed
like the rising power of the union
movement he was basically seen as a
potential totalitarian dictator of the
United States by the kind of people who
listened to Clarence Mannion where is
this picture of Barry Goldwater taken
where was it taken I don't know exactly
where it was taken it symbolized but it
symbolizes Barry Goldwater was and he
and he was a member of the Air National
Guard and he was a jet pilot and he was
damn proud to be a jet pilot he loved
the tool around the latest planes that
the that the defense contractors were
building and that was part of this image
that made him so attractive to the likes
of Bill Buckley and especially Clarence
Mannion conservatives worst
Cina stodgy old fat greedy he was young
youthful attractive well-spoken
adventurous and another thing that made
him attractive Clarence Mannion was you
had on the one hand you had southern
segregationists who weren't particularly
economically conservative and you had
northern Republicans who might be
conservative but the Republican Party
was just so hated in the south so they
couldn't decide whether they're
considered a candidate would be a
Democrat or a Republican
but then as Barry Goldwater won his
reelection in 1958 in a year when most
Republicans had lost resoundingly he
emerged as this kind of Republican hero
and one of the things he started doing
was speaking down south at meetings
these nascent Republican parties in the
southern states like South Carolina and
saying well I don't think Brown versus
Board of Education was such a good idea
you know maybe you guys in the south
have it right maybe the federal
government shouldn't be meddling in
states rights that was new that was a
new a new a new concept northern
Republican who appealed for popularity
in the south your book is about 650
pages long and it's impossible for us to
get to it all in this hour but there are
a number of little things I want to ask
you sir a name you see throughout the
book is currently Chief Justice of the
United States
what segregationist William Rehnquist
that's right how did you find him in
this story oh well he was great friends
with Barry Goldwater he was a leader in
the Phoenix Republican circles I mean
one way to find him is to look at the
transcripts of his confirmation hearing
as chief justice they went to great
detail about his activities in the
Republican Party in Arizona in 1962 he
was part of a crew that harassed black
and Hispanic voters to try and lower
Democratic totals and he was one of the
most prominent segregationists in
Phoenix I go why don't you know that I
mean how do you know he's welcome Barry
Goldwater was not a segregationist he
was a man who
who you know really saw everyone isn't
equal extremely honorable in his
personal dealings I'm matters of race
and in fact one of the things he worked
for was an open housing law in Phoenix
that same law Rehnquist testified
against a local lawyer he said our aim
should not be to have an integrated
society or a segregated society but a
free society he thought people should be
able to rent to people for whatever
reason they chose including their race
Barry Goldwater thought that was
important but he also thought that the
federal government shouldn't have any
say in the matter how do you know Bill
Rehnquist was a segregationist well he
stood up for the record before the
Phoenix City Council and said well okay
he wasn't an integrationist whether he
was a segregationist that's a matter for
semantics but he said we shouldn't pass
any anti segregation laws in the city
Phoenix because it's morally wrong how
much impact did he have on Barry
Goldwater in the campaign what role did
he play well one thing that happened
during the campaign that was
particularly historic was the debate
over the 1964 landmark Civil Rights Act
it was voted on I believe June 19th not
long before the Republican convention
was set to go into session and Barry
Goldwater was extremely torn it was a
time of enormous racial tension the
southerners were filibustering the bill
and African Americans were outraged it
really looked like kind of a civil war
situation and he had to decide whether
to [ __ ] his constitutionalist principles
and vote for a law that he really
thought was unconstitutional because it
dictated the behavior of private
business under the title 7 the civil
rights law employers are not allowed to
discriminate on the basis of race but
Barry Goldwater like a lot of
conservative businessman in the period
thought that people should be able to
hire whoever they want and he thought
that they would take a political police
force to enforce the law
he envisioned it as making America an
ugly place a distressful place and he
had to decide whether to vote for a bill
he probably knew would improve the
conditions of blacks or uphold his kind
of abstract principles and he really did
agonize over it and one of the things
that helped help the balance was a memo
from his friend Bell Rehnquist she said
you should have no hesitation about
signing voting against the civil rights
bill another guy who wrote him a 75 pH
memo was Robert Bork another friend of
his a Yale professor 64 in 1964 and
where was Robert Bork then he was a Yale
professor I believe use you say that 3.9
million people work for Goldwater mm-hmm
which was twice the number that worked
for LBJ in 1964 that's right and of
course LBJ got you know half again as
many votes how was he able to do that
very good
how could he find that many people work
for him well it's the difference between
a political campaign and a political
crusade conservatism was a crusade it
was a struggle for the soul of Western
civilization and though Lyndon Johnson
going back to those pundits in the
beginning Lyndon Johnson might have had
a mile-wide of popularity but it really
was ultimately an inch deep whereas
people would send Goldwater telegrams
you know as he was you know preparing
for the convention you know I'd give my
marrow of my bones for you you know I'll
stand by you like a soldier in combat
these were people who believed that
liberalism had to be stopped that we
needed to take a firm belligerent stand
against the Soviet Union we hadn't
talked about that and didn't think it
was just a matter of personal preference
but I literally am a doll or a matter of
the survival of Western civilization if
you believe that you have no problem
looking a couple envelopes to help the
cause you say that in 64 it was Barry
Goldwater in the in the primaries Nelson
Rockefeller Henry Cabot Lodge Williams
grant and George Romney Richard Nixon
and martyr chase Smith market chase
Smith yeah the first woman to run
a major Party presidential and
nomination did Henry Cabot Lodge ever
really want to run himself well you know
when you write a book and it's between
covers so you can't really change it I
have since found out from a guy who's
done research in Henry Cabot Lodge as
private papers who's also doing a book
on the 1964 election his name is Casey
Johnson that Henry Cabot Lodge was
secretly dictating a campaign that he
was supposed to have nothing to do with
he was writing handwritten notes to his
son that read destroy after reading
dictating exactly how his campaign
strategy should work and to the for all
the public knew and for all even Teddy
white knew and making the president 1964
the people who were running him for
president were doing it as a lark
without his permission
have you gotten any feedback on your
book from conservatives Oh Lots yeah a
lot of my most generous reviewers have
been conservatives Bill Kristol of the
Weekly Standard he reviewed the book in
the New York Times Book Review he said
you know time fly while I was having fun
or something like that he thought it was
a fun book what do you think of that
that's great I won't make people smile I
want to make people laugh politics is
fun and you know I got a generous review
from William rusher in the National
Review he's in your book throughout a
judo game over the bar out he was he was
very generous with this time set and
well we talked while he had a cigar at
his club in San Francisco and he really
opened up his his memories to me in a
way that was quite generous I thought
did you change your mind on anything
conservative as you went through this
process well I respect conservatives but
the main way I respect them is as
political strategists and technicians
and as people who had the courage to
break out of kind of centrism and timid
politics and fight for what they believe
I mean I argued this was a 60s movement
what that means is that like the new
left that came along later these were
people who were taking risks for what
they believed in weren't afraid to break
a few eggs in the process and you know
my personal opinion is you know we could
use a little more that these days you
write history humiliated London Johnson
yes it did in what way well one of the
things Lyndon Johnson used to say on the
campaign trail in fact he quoted it you
know this grand speech and the steps of
the Texas State Capitol in Austin was
that government is not the enemy of the
people government is the people he had
an unbounded faith in the the capacity
of government to create not just you
know to run society but to create a
great society one that would would would
would bring us you know unspoken of
bounty in terms of personal fulfillment
the rhetoric is beautiful but you know
by 1994 they're taking polls and people
are saying like seventy percent of
people are saying they don't trust the
government to accomplish anything you
know he lived wet till 1971 and it was
all you know for his vision of politics
which was twofold first that there was
no disagreement that was too great that
it couldn't be negotiated behind closed
doors in an amicable part of a kind of
way he loved to quote that Bible first
let us reason together and his belief in
activist Liberal government which turned
out to become less and less popular you
would have if he hadn't had died you
know when he did he certainly would have
died of a political broken heart now in
your book and you look back on it did
you do what's the breakup or the
breakdown of how much of this is you
learn from other books and how much of
you learn from interviews and your own
archives CIA archives I would say that
this has without the majesty a pretty
high percentage of original research
like tell us what areas that you thought
all the stuff about Clarence Mannion has
only been glanced at before but I went
down to Chicago and where it went
through all his letters at the Chicago
Historical Society for anyone who wants
to study conservatism in the 50s and 60s
and now in the graduate schools there a
lot of them a great place to start is
Clarence manion's archives at the
Chicago store
society you know that's that's that's
one of the major chunks that's new
certainly I did a lot of primary
research and the draft Goldwater
movement between 1961 and 1964 the
conservatives who almost within without
Barry Goldwater's knowledge at first and
certainly without his blessing started
scooping up all these precinct
organizations and state after state but
you know I really stand in the shoulders
of some really strong both scholarship
and journalism you know I when whenever
whenever someone writes about it
mentions the book these days assume they
say Rick Pearlstein argues that X well
people always said X but now I get
credit for things that are not
necessarily new what about John Birch
Society and Robert Welsh did you find
out anything new about that and what was
the relationship of the John Birch
Society to Clarence Mannion to Bill
Buckley and to Barry Kohler well I'm
probably the only left winger in the
United States is read four or five books
by Robert Welch who was he Robert Welch
was he was Wow he was a child prodigy
graduated from college at the age of
thirteen or fourteen I didn't believe
that I didn't trust that so I called a
registrar at the University of North
Carolina and you know nailed down the
fact he what came from a rural family he
was intellectual prodigy who failed in a
few endeavors as a writer as a law
student and eventually took up a
position in his brothers Candy Company
in Massachusetts the Welsh candy country
the Welch candy company I think they
made some kind of daddy or mother or
sugar or something and if I'm just
calling they're in sales he was not only
a passionate salesman of the product he
was selling but he was a passionate
salesman for his vision of absolutely
unadulterated free-market capitalism
he he thought he wrote a book called the
road to salesmanship and what she said
that salesmen are more important to
American society than
actors or lawyers or anyone because they
were the people who they were the people
who who stimulated people to want more
and when you want more you work hard and
it's kind of Calvinist idea of virtue
through work and self-improvement and
then you know of course once once once
World War two ends and people start
focusing on the a number one threat to
this idea which was of course Soviet
Communism he becomes absolutely obsessed
by it and he builds this absolutely
fantastic intellectual system on a
foundation of to fix the foundation
being that everything that happens that
goes against unadulterated free-market
capitalism
probably had something to do with the
conspiracy by Moscow agents working in
the United States and he got a
surprising following I by starting with
John Birch Society because there was so
little outlet for expression for people
who believed in free market capitalism
it was such kind of a marginal idea in
this time of consensus when people
accepted Keynes in our economics the
liberal welfare state that you know
people joined up this group the media
got wind of it they got wind of the fact
that he had written that President
Dwight Eisenhower was a conscious agent
of the communist conspiracy they looked
at all these members he had and all
these flowers and said this is really
scary we may have a fascist revolt on
her hands in America what was his
relationship to Manion and Buckley and
Goldwater hmm Manion was the supporter
down the line he was a member member the
board other William Buckley has actually
denied that but I think historically
that doesn't hold water William F
Buckley and Barry Goldwater were very
much part of a movement to write him out
of the standard of the conservative
movement I mean that's one of the dramas
in the book how they tried to you know
pick him up by the lapels and just you
know kick him out another drama of the
book is this picture it's the last
picture in the book where was it taken
that is what they call a video capture
played a videotape and you know got an
image from it the videotape was of
Ronald Reagan's October 27 1964 speech
nationally-televised
on behalf of Barry Goldwater days before
the election a week before the election
and there was all kinds of Sterman drawn
within the high circles of the Goldwater
campaign whether to allow this crackpot
actor to take their precious television
time basically all of Goldwater's
biggest california funders threatened to
basically withhold their money unless
they put Reagan on the air he was their
hero in his laboratory and that's right
homes total same people who came to be
called Reagan's kitchen cabinet when he
became governor and they were Southern
California conservatives often from
Orange County and Ronald Reagan went on
the air and he just spellbound the
nation people would call their
conservative friends the next day and
say you know you've been talking all
this crazy talk for the last thing you
know months about Goldwater I seen this
Reagan guy and I finally understand what
you're talking about though the the
Republican Party was really looking to
end the campaign with a rather profound
economic deficit but so much money
started pouring in after Ronald Reagan
went on the air that the end of the
campaign in surplus what did that do to
Ronald Reagan well it made him the man
of the hour
he was able to inherit these armies that
were built up in the process of trying
to nominate an elect Barry Goldwater one
the governor ship of California what did
that six well it said things that were
similar to what Barry Goldwater was
saying but he had a sparkling he was the
great communicator he was able to use
these metaphors they're connected with
people or as Barry Goldwater kind of
assumed that people already knew what he
was talking about he was used to talking
to Republicans used to talking to
conservatives he didn't really think he
had to meet people halfway he he was
good speaker to conservatives he was a
poor speaker to a general audience and
one of the things the speech said was
that social security should be made
voluntary Goldwater had said that early
on in the campaign in the New Hampshire
primary and that had done so much
political damage
and they never mentioned it again but
Ronald Reagan was able to explain it in
a way that it didn't sound crazy anymore
is where did you find out that Barry
Goldwater never called up either Ronald
Reagan or Nancy Reagan and thanked him
for that speech I'd have to check the
footnote that might have been in Nancy
Reagan's memoir were you surprised to
hear that
no that Trek was very global ours
personality Barry Goldwater could be
petty he was pretty much a large salt
man but look I mean place yourself in
Barry Goldwater shoes which is something
you know I've been doing all this time
he has suffered the vilest possible
abuse for months and months totally
unfair abuse about how he's gonna blow
up the world I mean that's what most
people remember about the Barry
Goldwater campaign how hated he was he
was seen as a fascist the American
Hitler and he bust his hump for months
and months to try and get his message
across and suddenly in comes this guy on
a you know on a magic carpet and seems
to be scooping up all the harder and
organizational support that you know he
had helped build with his hands and then
there's this quote from Lyndon Johnson
on October the 21st in Akron Ohio you
put in your book we are not going to
send American boys 9 or 10 thousand
miles away from home to do what Asian
boys ought to be doing for themselves
yeah well let's remember what he said
next he always balanced his statements
of those sort he would say that and then
you would say but if anyone messes with
America you know we'll be on their tail
but at the same time as we all know and
this is another fact that I get credit
for bringing up but really was kind of
floating around for a long time he was
you know planning the bombing of North
Vietnam when he was saying those things
where's your home or is Lee I grew up in
the suburbs of Milwaukee and your
parents you mentioned they were are they
conservatives I think they're they're
politically idiosyncratic my mom they're
not they're not political they don't
read books on politics
they read this one now that now that the
book is over we define your politics
today I am a european-style social
democrat I proudly identify with the
left-wing tradition that has given
America universal education the the
progressive income tax some kind of old
age insurance and I think that leftists
have nothing to be ashamed of we can
march in the future and we I believe
that we can actually take back the
center of American politics from
conservatives because we're right Rick
Pearlstein has written this book here's
the cover it's before the storm all
about Barry Goldwater and the 1964
campaign we thank you very much for
joining us thanks for having me